hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book two of his work on anger
particularly in one chapter number 10
Seneca is going to consider
errors and the fact that we tend to get
angry at errors or mistakes when people
go wrong whether we think that it's
deliberate in some sense or they were
just being negligent and ignorant and
foolish we often do get angry with them
we have this response and so he begins
the chapter by saying that you should
contemplate the thought is one way it's
translated or just straight out think
about cookie tobus and it's actually
saying you you will think about right
and what is it that we should think
about what is it we should mull over
that we shouldn't get angry at errors
and you might say well why shouldn't we
get angry at errors people are making
dumb mistakes that they should know
better well that may be what that may be
true but that doesn't mean that we
ourselves have to get angry and he's
going to provide us with some you you
know Fuller thoughts here for you might
say working ourselves out of the
knee-jerk response of seeing somebody
doing something wrong and then getting
upset with it and he's going to give us
a lot of examples as well before we look
at his his thought process he says what
if you were to become angry at people
unable to put one foot surely after
another in the dark so people are
walking along and there's no street
lights there's no phones to illuminate
anything there's no flashlights or
torches they're just stumbling along
they they don't know right and if they
trip and fall well that's kind of to be
expected or he says that deaf people who
don't listen to orders why would you
expect a deaf person to listen to orders
or at children because they don't pay
attention to their duties but look
instead to their age mates games and
silly jokes what if you should choose to
become angry at the those who grow sick
or old or tired in all of these
conditions people are screwing up but
they they're screwing up precisely
because they don't know better or
whatever it is that they could have done
to prepare they didn't do it right and
this is extremely common in life and
Seneca is going to say oh this is The
Human Condition so you know don't think
of yourself as this perfect person who
never makes any mistakes instead think
about the way human beings are and the
things that he's saying you know two
Millennia ago are pretty true today so
he says a few things here among all
those other disadvantages in komoda is
the Latin for that things that are you
know getting in our way things that are
off-putting that are ours as Mortals as
vulnerable creature right there's this
he says the murkiness the caligo there's
a sort of like fogginess the shadowiness
of our minds
and this leads to he says the
inevitability of our mistakes so
necessitasitas you could translate as
necessity right you may not screw up
every single time or you might not even
scrub half the time or 90 of the time
but you are going to screw up every
human being is going to screw up because
our minds are kind of a a mess right so
inevitability of our mistakes they're
the the term is irandi Right a gerundive
uh we're going to air we're going to go
astray and then he says it also leads to
a fondness or even love or desire for
our errors and there he uses erroribus
right uh so you know the plural of
Errors not only do we inevitably make
mistakes we don't necessarily love the
mistakes as such but we love the paths
that lead us there and a little bit
later he's gonna you know take this back
up after giving us some more advice he
will say that being you know human is is
a sort of excuse these are the terms and
stipulations of our birth This Is What
You Get by being a human being
we are creatures subject to no fewer
diseases of Mind than of body and in a
way by being rational creatures having a
greater capacity for Thought than the
other animals as far as we can tell we
have greater capacity to go astray right
so he says we're neither dull nor slow
but misusing our Acuity all of us
offering each other
examples of vices vices are you know bad
uh emotional reactions bad habits uh
whenever anyone follows those who have
gone before down the wrong route how
could they not have had an excuse since
they've gone astray on the common
highway right
we human beings screw up a lot and we
follow each other's stupid examples as
well so now here we get to those are
some considerations here we get to like
what we could actually do and Seneca
suggests something actually quite
extraordinary here if we want to keep
from anger at individual people to not
get angry at this particular person this
particular person then one of the things
that we can do is he says forgive
everybody forgive the entire human race
universes
is is what he says now ignoscendum is
not exactly the same thing or ignoscory
as parkare to forgive right or to Pardon
it more means something like not to pay
attention to to overlook to deliberately
put out of your mind what it is that
people in general do and he goes on and
he says you should Grant a pardon to the
human race and the grant a pardon there
is Veni Venia trebuendo sovenia are you
know little things where people do the
wrong thing we get the word venial from
that when people make a distinction you
know in religious terms between venial
and Mortal sins right venial sins are
the kinds of screw-ups that we do all
the time like you know not tying my tie
right or uh you know forgetting
somebody's name that can't get on the
tip of my tongue as I'm looking at them
and I'm like hey you we've all done that
sort of thing so Venia are these these
things that are very common
means that we should Grant these we
should overlook these we should be okay
with these and we should do that to the
entire human race
he's actually got a very interesting
consideration he's like well you know we
excuse children for things because
children are stupid they're
underdeveloped they're not mature right
well we should grant that same sort of
Pardon to humanity in general he says
being human is a greater excuse and a
more just one than being a child and so
what we can do is you know realize that
the human race is screwed up he says
what eliminates a wise man's anger the
great crowd of wrongdoers he understands
how unjust that is and how dangerous to
be angry with a vice that is pandemic
that that affects all of us including
the wise person and he talks about uh
two wise people in particular from
Antiquity very distant from Seneca you
know by hundreds and hundreds of you
years and then he talks about the wise
person in general and what they're going
to do and this is a typical Seneca theme
laughing versus crying they're both
emotional reactions to things laughing
he thinks is better than crying they're
both uh in a certain sense wise
reactions though heraclitus would go out
in public he says whenever heraclitus
left his home and saw about him such a
mass of people living badly he wept wept
for what out of pity for all the happy
and prosperous people he met the
behavior of a mind that was gentle but
two week
besides he himself was among those
deserving of the tears so you know this
is a better response than the run of the
mill but it's still not the best
response what about Democritus he says
Democritus was never without a smile in
public so hard did he find it to take
seriously all the transactions being
conducted in Earnest where is the place
for anger there right so these are two
different options that we have if we
want to pursue this and Seneca does talk
about these these people elsewhere in
his works so he says all things deserve
either
our laughter or our tears pity for those
who are screwing up laughter at those
who are screwing up not the laughter
that's like you jackass but just you
know gentle laughter so those are two
options and then he talks about what a
wise person leaving their house is going
to do and if you're familiar with stoic
uh writings you you should probably see
a connection here between this
observation and Marcus aurelius's
meditations book two chapter one where
he says in the morning when you wake up
you know say to yourself I'm going to
run into a bunch of jackasses roughly
paraphrasing there so he says that the
wise person calm and even tempered in
the face of error right is going to
not be an enemy of wrongdoers but one
who sets them straight leaves his house
daily with this thought in mind I will
encounter many people who are to drink
many who are lustful many who are
ungrateful many who are greedy many who
are driven by the demon of ambition and
he says all such behaviors he will
regard as kindly as a doctor does his
own patience a good doctor right not a
bad doctor somebody who's just in it for
the money or to have power over patients
or criticize them a good doctor he'll be
like oh you poor thing
you know if you'll help let me I'll help
you out so you're not going to be so
miserable if you're not well then you're
gonna have to suffer right and so this
is something that would be distinctive
to the approach of the the wise person
as Seneca considers it so you know one
main source for us getting upset are
these minor things that we call errors
or mistakes or screwing up and so you
know if we can adopt the right attitude
Seneca says if we can think the right
thoughts contemplate it then we can
avoid falling into anger at least on
those sorts of occasions